في عاصمه روسيا القيصريه سابقا حل الوفد
الافريقي الوسيط للقاء الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين بعد يوم من زياره للعاصمه كييف
والاستماع الى رفض الرئيس زيلينسكي
التفاوض مع موسكو الحكم الغربي المسبق
بفشل المبادره الافريقيه لانهاء الحرب
التي تهز اوروبا لم يمنع القاده من مواصله
رحلتهم ولقاءاتهم مع طرفي النزاع
المباشرين روسيا واوكرانيا لم يسمع الضيوف
كلاما جديدا لافسا بترسبرج ولا فيكياف عن
شروط كل طرف للحوار ووقف القتال لكن
الرئيس بوتين اشاد بمقاربه متوازنه للدول
الافريقيه بشان حرب اوكرانيا
نحن منفتحون على اجراء حوار بناء مع كل من
يريدون السلام على اساس مبادئ العداله
ومراعاه المصالح المشروعه للطرفين تنص
المبادره الافريقيه على انسحاب القوات
الروسيه وازاله الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
من بيلاروسيا وتعليق مذكره التوقيف
الصادره من المحكمه الجنائيه بحق الرئيس
بوتين ما يسمح بتوفير البيئه المناسبه
لوقف اطلاق النار حتى قبل ان تبدا صرح
حلفاء اكياف ان الوساطه الافريقيه هي
الاضعف وبان فرص فشلها هي الاكبر بيد ان
موسكو تنظر الى هؤلاء بشكل مختلف من منطلق
تغيير التحالفات وجذب اطراف جديده الى
المعسكرات التي افرزتها حسابات الحرب
العابره للقارات
باجنداتها المختلفه
موقفكير من الوساطه الاخيره والتي سبقتها
سلبي انها لا تريد السلام لاوكرانيا بل
الاستسلام هكذا وصفها مستشار الرئيس
زيلينسكي
هم لا يعرضون خطه للسلام بل يعرضون
استسلام اوكرانيا كل هذه الخطط
الاندونيسيه والافريقيه والصينيه
والبرازيليه واي مبادره سوف نسمعها غير
صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه التي توضح بشكل
عملي ودقيق الطريق الى السلام ليست خطط
سلام بل هي دعوات لاستسلام اوكرانيا
دعوه اوكرانيا لانضمامها سريعا الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي طلب بعيد المنال كلام الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يعكس الموقف المعروف عن
الانقسام داخل الحلف بشان مساله تعجيل
الانضمام التي تعارضها واشنطن والمانيا
والمجر
د
ينبغي ان تنطبق عليهم المعايير نفسها هذا
يعني اننا لن نسهل امرا انضمام البلد الذي
يواجه هجوما عسكريا روسيا لا مشكله في
تقديم دعم عسكري غير مسبوق للقوات
الاوكرانيه لكن الالتحاق بالنيتو واحتمال
تفعيل البند الخامس قضيه اخرى تستدعي
تريثا لا يعجبك
على ارض المعركه يسعى كل طرف لتحقيق مكاسب
عسكريه او على الاقل الحفاظ على ما تحقق
لضمان اوراق ضغط اكبر في حال التفاوض
المؤجل الى حين تتحدث عن تقدم في المراحل
الاولى لهجومها المضاد تحديدا في الجنوب
وموسكو تقول انها دمرت احد مراكز صنع
القرار للقوات الاوكرانيه والتصدي لهجوم
على مصفاه للنفط فيبريونسك الحرب والسلام
مفردتان يبدو ان الوقت لم يحن بعد لتشتمع
معا هنا السلاح فقط هو اللغه التخاطب بين
روسيا واوكرانيا